It is great to welcome back to the program
today.
Dr. Isaac WBO, gosh, who's an infectious disease
physician and scientists based out of the
University of Toronto and Toronto General
Hospital.
Always great to talk to you.
Nice to see you again.
So I guess just to start with briefly, we're
seeing the U.S. number of corona virus cases
down from their sort of second peak, still
around 40000 cases a day.
I know you're in Canada.
I don't know how closely you're following
the ins and outs of case numbers here, but
there's some skepticism about whether these
case numbers can be trusted at this point,
given a lot of different things that have
gone on with the data, with testing pause
due to weather events and so many other things.
My question to you is, is there really a better
metric to pay attention to at this point,
be it hospitalizations or deaths or something
else?
In all fairness, I look at a combination of
metrics.
I think the number of new cases per day is
very, very helpful.
But above and beyond that, I look at other
metrics as well.
I look at the seven day average.
I look at the number of tests that are performed.
Look at the percentage of tests that are positive
out of the number of tests that are performed.
And I really think that when we sort of combine
all of those metrics and more, we really paint
a more holistic picture that gives us a better
understanding.
Of course, if testing isn't being done, if
it's hard to know exactly what the ground
truth is.
But in all fairness, I think it's by this
point in time, we sort of know in most regions
how things are going and what direction things
are turning, either for better or for worse.
So one specific question on testing and positivity.
Sometimes we will see a situation where it
looks like in a particular state, cases have
gone down.
And then when you look in a little more detail,
you see that tests are down 30 percent and
new cases are only down 10 percent, which
implies a higher positivity rate.
And it suggests that it's because you're doing
less testing, that cases have gone down.
The counter point is, well, you know, if the
testing goes down, you're probably only testing
sicker people.
So it makes sense that the positivity rate
would go up.
It doesn't necessarily mean there are actually
more cases out there.
Is there any way to know for sure?
Well, yes, there is.
And the real answer is getting lots of disparate
data sources together in one place.
And really, that is why it is so important
to look at several metrics rather than just
relying on a handful of metrics.
And then, of course, watching the metrics
through time, an individual day or even a
few days really does nothing to us.
It's really important to look at longer term
trends, seven day trends and beyond.
And I think if we're starting to do that and
stop reacting to, you know, terms like uptick
and downtick, every time we see some variation
in the data, we'll be in a much better place.
There's going to be the expected normal variations
on a day to day basis and even maybe on a
bit of a longer term basis.
But if we look at weekly trends and look at
multiple data sources, I think we'll be in
the right place.
And really, truly, all of those combined together
give us gives us a good impression.
I don't think anyone following this is really
looking at that one true metric that's really
going to provide all the answers.
It's it's a multitude of metrics.
So let's talk about the next three to four
months.
Some of the countries that did successfully
flatten their curves are starting to see some
more cases.
Spain is one example that I've been looking
at.
And there are many others in the United States.
When we first got down to 20000 cases a day,
things just basically reopened and we went
all the way back up to 75.
Now we're back down to 40.
What is the best assessment now of what was
originally thought of in the May projections
to be a discrete second wave, which now is
just maybe going to be a kind of continuation?
What is the timing looking like?
How bad could it potentially get?
It's interesting because we talk about the
second wave like it has some finite definition.
And in all fairness, I don't think it really
matters whether or not this is a spike in
the first wave, a plateau in the first wave.
But this thing, second wave, I think a lot
of this is irrelevant in the sense that, number
one, you still have a very susceptible population,
meaning that, you know, in most places, the
vast majority of people have not had this
infection so are susceptible to getting this
infection.
And number two, if you don't have controls
in place to keep this infection at bay, you're
going to see widespread transmission.
So, you know, if we look in the crystal ball
a lot, there's you know, if we can predict
what's going to happen, if people are in indoor
environments, in close proximity for prolonged
periods of time, we know that this is the
perfect setup for transmission.
Now, let's think about what's going to happen
in the months ahead, at least in the northern
parts of the United States.
It's going to get cool.
We've got kids going back to school.
We've got many people going back to work in
person.
We've got cooler temperatures that are driving
us inside.
We've got economies that are opening and all
of those just put people together in indoor
environments for prolonged periods of time.
That is where this virus is transmitted.
If we take steps to mitigate that, spread
people apart, put a mask on when you go inside,
limit the number of people in indoor settings.
We can probably do a decent job in mitigating
the spread.
But I still think we'll probably see a rise
in cases, at least in the northern part of
the United States and certainly in Canada
as we enter the fall and winter months.
So in terms of masks, obviously there's been
a lot about masks over the last many months
in particular.
There is disagreement, I guess we can say,
about the degree to which masks prevent transmission
and whether they're really to protect one
from spreading versus to protect one from
catching or both.
There's a very popular meme that's been floating
around which assert, you know, it puts numbers
to it where it says both people wear a mask.
It's like a one percent chance of transmission.
If one person wears a masks it mask, it's
five percent.
If neither one does, it's fit or whatever,
right?
Yeah, I'm sure those aren't the right numbers.
But are there any numbers or specificity to
the effect of masks?
And then, of course, what type of mask, I'm
guessing is a factor as well.
Right.
I think we can talk about this in general
principles.
And, you know, I certainly just full disclosure,
mass is probably my least favorite topic of
this epidemic or pandemic.
Interesting.
For whatever reason, this was like the hot
button issue.
This was politicized to such a degree.
People have very, very strong opinions on
on many different sides of the equation.
People are cherry picking data to suit their
preconceived ideas.
And it's really frustrating when you really
want to just take a public health look at
this and epidemiologic look at it on medical
and scientific.
Look at it.
It's kind of frustrating.
And quite frankly, it's frustrating because
people who should know better are are still,
I think, speaking beyond the data or still
cherry picking data.
Having said that, there are many rational
voices both in the lake community and them
and in the medical, scientific and public
health community.
And I commend those people because anytime
we talk about this, for whatever reason, there
seems to be a dogpile effect.
Now, let's get to the question.
So in general, based on what we know now,
we can talk about mass at an individual level
and we can also talk about masks at a population
level.
I think we can also talk about mass in a health
care specific area as well.
But in general, at an individual level, if
you put a mask on and you're infected, you're
just going to reduce the amount of virus that
you transmit to the environments around you.
Seems to make sense.
Pretty good idea.
Now, does this pan out at a population level?
It's interesting.
There's modeling studies, which quite frankly,
I know I work in epidemiology as well.
And you know what?
My career is based on working with modeling
and whatnot.
I've got to say, like, I should be the big
supporter of models.
I think models are helpful, but I don't think
they really answer definitively the questions
that we want to answer.
They're helpful.
They're useful.
But we have to take a lot of the modeling
data with a grain of salt.
So at an individual level.
Great.
I think it's a no brainer.
We've known this long before Koban 19.
If you put on a mask, you just reduce the
amount of virus you're going to shed in the
environment around you at a population level.
The waters get a bit murkier.
Will it really help at a population level
if there's masking?
Yeah.
You know, what is the end of the day?
If we sift through the data, it probably helps.
But I think it helps to a much smaller extent
than what many people might believe or might
want to believe.
But I'm not saying it doesn't help.
I think it.
And then, you know, how do you take this data
and translate into policy?
I think at the end of the day, we also know
where this virus is transmitted.
It's almost, well, I should say exclusively,
but it's truly an indoor virus.
Like, there's just remarkably few transmission
of this virus that are credible, that have
been documented in outdoor settings.
Cherkin happened in an outdoor setting, but
it's just not nearly as common as indoor setting.
So we take our data that we have with mass,
with the total appreciation that this is imperfect
data, with the total appreciation that it's
going to be impossible to know at this point
to have a perfect randomized double blind.
Civil control trial or whatever we want to
design.
But if we take the existing data that we have,
I think it's very reasonable to translate
that into policy, to say, listen, if you're
in an indoor setting, you should put on a
mask.
I think it's as simple as that outdoors.
I mean, I've seen some of the narratives coming
out of the United States with people saying,
you know, I went for a 20 k jog and I had
a mask on my whole time.
And then this didn't bother me one bit, you
know, mazeltov.
We're all very proud of you for wearing a
mask.
But like, I don't think you're at risk of
transmitting this infection if you're on a
28 jog.
You probably don't need to worry about.
I focus on indoor settings.
I think Masser a great idea taken the politics
out of it.
We should be putting on a mask when we go
indoors.
Yeah.
I mean, I said we don't let's we'll move on
after this.
But here in Boston now if you're just even
walking downtown, if you don't have a mask
on, you know, people can kind of look at you
from the studies I've looked at.
It really doesn't seem like that is at all
a high risk scenario.
But if people want to do it, like you said,
mazeltov, you know, like I am, I'll do it
all.
I'll do it in order to participate, because
I don't want to be the person who is not participating.
But it doesn't really seem to be based too
much in the science.
I think you have a really good point there.
And a lot of this bleeds well out of science
and medicine and into more sociological or
socio political conversation.
I'm sitting here in Toronto.
I can not comment.
I cannot empathize on what you're going through
in the United States in terms of the degree
of politicization that this has had.
And if the mask might also represent a lot
more than, hey, I'm I'm here to keep you safe
in case I'm infected.
And I appreciate that there's a lot more going
on in the United States with regards to that
than there is in Canada.
It might be a signal that I align with this
particular group or that I have these particular
beliefs.
And in all fairness, I'm not into shaming
and blaming.
People want to wear a mask, go for it, wear
a mask.
But like where I would be more of a stickler
about it is indoor setting.
I think it's important that people put them
on when they go inside.
I think that will actually have some utility
in preventing the transmission of this infection.
OK, so vaccines.
Multiple vaccine candidates on spec production
of a number of them so that if indeed we learn
this one is a go or that one is a go.
Doses will be available.
Makes perfect sense.
Russia claims to have a vaccine, which has
a number of questions around it at this point.
My thought has been the optimistic scenario
is somewhere around October 15, there's an
announcement made that a vaccine is safe and
at least gives four or five months of immunity.
It starts to be rolled out slowly.
Health care workers maybe by the end of the
year, 2021.
High risk populations.
Is that still the optimistic scenario?
Where where are we on vaccines?
Yeah.
I mean, the pace of vaccine development is
just staggering.
This is phenomenal.
There's about two dozen that are in human
clinical trials.
Remember, we know this infection existed seven
months ago and now seven months in.
You've got just over two dozen human clinical
trials.
I think right now there's six or seven that
are in what's called phase three human clinical
studies.
That's amazing.
I mean, that's that's where you're enrolling
thousands and thousands and thousands of people
to answer the question.
Does it work?
And is it safe?
So, you know, there's there's tremendous pace.
And of course, we know many of these vaccines
are going to fail.
But there's so many that are in development
and even in advanced stages of development
that I'm with you.
I do share that optimistic outlook that we'll
probably have some successful trials in before
the end of 2020.
I wouldn't be surprised if needle start going
in arms before the end of 2020.
Hey, I could be totally wrong.
I could be way off and it could be 20, 21,
and these might be a bust.
But looking at the data that we have available
to us is pretty promising.
It's not you know, nothing, of course, is
guaranteed.
But I share that.
I share that view.
I also like that concept where many governments,
or I guess in partnership with the companies
just say, you know what, let's just mass produce
these vaccines now.
We appreciate that.
We might be tossing a billion dollars out
the window if it doesn't work.
But.
The ones that do work, we can already start
to rollout vaccine programs.
That's a really smart idea.
You've got money to burn.
That's a great way to spend it, because I
think at the end of the day, when you balance
the economics of lost versus gained, I think
this will likely side towards a net gain.
I'm not a health economics type of guy, but
I'm pretty sure that that's the way that the
tables will turn, or at least whatever the
word.
You know what I'm trying to say?
Now, when it starts to become available, it
takes a while before we really get towards
being able to say we have ended the pandemic.
Right.
I mean, it's when you took my belief.
My understanding is with something as contagious
as coronavirus, about 70 percent immunity
is required for herd.
40 percent of the U.S. is not even interested
in getting the vaccine, which is a totally
different story.
But this once the vaccine rolls out, it's
still going to be a while, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
I don't think this pandemic's going to end
with a bang, but more with a whimper.
Right.
It's probably going to peter out as more and
more people get vaccinated or as more and
more people get this infection and then recover
from it and have some degree of immunity for
some period of time.
So it's probably going to peter out.
I think the other thing that it's not talked
about a lot is even though we'll have access
to this vaccine in many high income countries.
This pandemic is still going to be raging
in many other parts of the world, especially
in low income countries that sadly are, you
know, might not have the same access to the
vaccine that you and I will have.
And and I think there's going to be a lot
of individuals and a significant proportion
of the globe that will be suffering, disproportionately
suffering because of limited access to the
vaccine, because many of the high income countries
are buying it all up and snatching it all
up.
And and, you know, I really hope I know that
there are programs I know that WHL was looking
into this and there are groups looking into
this to really have more equitable vaccine
programs worldwide.
But, you know, part of me is a little bit
skeptical as to how successful those will
be.
Oh, we're going to go to a break on the podcast
and radio show with Dr. Isaac Bogot.
But our full conversation is well beyond the
YouTube channel.